surely nearly gone on wednesday morning
the number of government resignations
was still less than 10. by the afternoon
the dam had burst and boris johnson's
support was draining away
mr speaker there's a very simple reason
why they want me out at the regular
session of prime minister's questions
the commons chamber became a bear pit
the prime minister under attack from all
sides does the prime minister think
there are any circumstances in which he
should resign
[Applause]
today i ask him to do the honorable
thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
mr speaker isn't this the first recorded
case of the sinking ships fleeing the
rats
the job of a prime minister in difficult
circumstances when he's been handed a
colossal mandate is to keep going and
that's what i'm going to do
immediately afterwards sajid javid the
cabinet minister who was the first to
quit on tuesday returned to parliament
to explain his decision to mps and with
the prime minister listening javid
didn't pull any punches at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now
the final straw was downing street's
handling of complaints against this man
chris pincher pincher was given a
government job despite previous
allegations being upheld about him
making unwanted sexual advances to male
staffers
boris johnson claimed he didn't know
about the past misconduct in fact it
emerged that johnson had been briefed in
person about it
the situation is fast approaching a
tipping point where surely boris
johnson's position becomes untenable but
this is a prime minister possessed of
almost visceral stubbornness seemingly
impervious to the criticism of even
close colleagues and he will not leave
this place willingly
the question was posed directly during
johnson's appearance before the commons
liaison committee just on a very human
level surely you must know that
it's in the country's interest for you
to leave now isn't it i look at the um
the pressures of people uh are under and
the need for government to focus on that
on on on their priorities i look at uh
the biggest war in europe for 80 years
and uh i cannot for the life of me
see or how it is responsible just to
walk away from that ousting a prime
minister is no trivial matter but with
so many choosing to resign rather than
serve with this prime minister his
situation really does start to look
unsurvivable the question then becomes
how to actually remove him from office
paul brennan al jazeera downing street
well let's go straight to nadine barber
at downing street so 38 resignations and
counting nadim and it also looks like
other mps are also going to pile on the
pressure for him to go what more can you
tell us
neva is astonishing how quickly the
resignations have
poured in
since tuesday evening when sajid javid
and rishi sunak resigned
from cabinet an astonishing situation in
number 10 here because there are said to
be two groups of cabinet members now
some who are waiting to tell boris
johnson in no uncertain terms that he
should go otherwise they will quit and
another group who are still backing him
one of the people who are going to tell
him that he should step down even though
as you've just heard he says it's in no
one's interest in his opinion for him to
walk away one of them is nadine zahawi
he's the person who just
stood stood into the
vacant post of chancellor uh and less
than 24 hours later
he's delivering that message to um the
prime minister now um in the uh
parliamentary session of parliament
prime minister's question times earlier
kirstama focused on the reaction
to um chris um chris pincher's um
appointment and basically accused boris
johnson of enabling uh somebody that he
called a sexual predator
some of the people who've been resigning
have referred to the same problem and
one of the latest um mps has said that
um the government and boris johnson have
been turning a blind eye
to sexual assault this is really serious
stuff boris johnson of course has
apologized says with hindsight he made a
mistake but this gets back to um what he
was supposed to have done after all the
other scandals after partygate for
example cleaning up downey street and
cleaning up the messaging the way the
government operates not only that though
he's now going to be told that there are
not enough people to fill the new the
vacant positions
uh nadim just just uh looking at boris
johnson's performance in parliament
earlier he's almost seemed to have made
a political career of apologizing
recently
sometimes his apologies are more be more
effusive than others just looking at his
performance considering he was accused
of being part of a government of zed
list nodding dogs by kierstarma did this
look like a prime minister who was
embattled in your eyes
he looks frustrated exasperated there
were lots of sighs uh on wednesday
afternoon at the uh
commons liaison committee he was
actually asked um about what he would do
if he lost another vote of no confidence
that could happen fairly soon the
backbencher committee the 1922 committee
met today decided not to change the
rules but they're going to meet on
monday to form a new executive and then
it's understood that there will be a
push to change the rules so there can be
another vote would he push for an early
election rather than stepping down in
the end he said no but he said no one
was calling no one wanted an election
but then he was asked directly would you
resign and he really didn't address that
scenario i mean it's astounding that
we've got to that point where so many of
his colleagues are telling him to go or
they'll quit but it's quite possible
though that at least until next week he
could remain in his post
and team barber live for us on downing
street thank you
well boris johnson could face a fresh
vote of confidence in the 1922 committee
if the 1922 committee rather changes its
rules let's see how this can happen
the committee is made up of 18 tory
backbencher mps they meet weekly to
discuss party matters but crucially set
rules in which a leader can be ousted
johnson survived a vote of confidence
last month he now has one year's
immunity under the current rules but the
committee has met to consider changing
that a decision could be made later on
wednesday if it decides in favor 15
percent of the party would need to write
to committee chairman sir graham brady
to demand a fresh vote johnson's press
secretary says he will challenge a bid
to oust him
all right let's bring in alex dean a
conservative political commentator he
joins us
live now from uh london um are we
looking at the final hours of uh johnson
government
well by definition no i mean you've
taken us through the timetable
accurately i think the 1922 committee
would have to have a new executive
election dale executive would have to
want to change the rules there would
then have to be 15 of the party uh
wanting to have a vote that one's a
given uh then the prime minister would
have to face a vote of confidence in him
and he might win that right it may seem
unlikely but we've seen in many times in
recent events that if you've got a
binary vote coming up it's wise to
consider both sides of the potential
outcomes uh we nobody predicted brexit
amongst the pundits few predicted donald
trump winning the prime minister i
suppose could win
an election held amongst members of
parliament but i see the prime minister
right now certainly as wounded but not
killed
there do seem to be a growing number of
conservative mps that are determined
to see him out of office um
[Music]
that's that's fair except the one thing
we've got to bear in mind is that
innuendo can become fact i thought
paul's report just now is very good but
we are people are tempted to report and
say what's being said behind closed
doors as if we definitely know and we
don't know what some of those senior
cabinet ministers are saying to the
prime minister we know that they have
said they're not resigning two have done
of course but rishi sunak and sadi javed
will be disappointed that moore didn't
follow them the rest of the cabinet have
decided to stay where they are and
whilst we can speculate about what
they're saying to the prime minister
it's not actually the case to say that
we know what would be hypothetically a
critically damaging blow for the for the
prime minister would it be another key
cabinet member going somebody like
michael go for instance
i i don't think so actually i think the
prime minister will not let the fates
and decisions of individuals determine
whether he remains at number 10 there
are two things that could mean at the
end of boris johnson's time as prime
minister the first is losing a vote of
confidence amongst conservative members
of parliament and the second would be
losing a vote of no confidence against
the government on the floor of the house
of commons itself and i don't see the
latter happening i don't see the tories
voting uh with labour to try to bring
down their own government so in the end
it's going to be up to the members of
the conservative party to decide whether
they want boris johnson to stay as prime
minister boris johnson has repeatedly
talked about having a massive mandate to
lead
given that he was at the helm during a
landslide election at the last general
election that is indeed true but if the
polls are to be believed the labour
party 11 points ahead boys johnson
doesn't have the confidence of the
nation by the looks of things
well we had a general election
relatively recently and as you rightly
say boris johnson won a thumping
majority now people are always fond of
saying the only opinion poll that really
matters is the one that's conducted at
the ballot box well a proportion of
people who voted conservative will think
with some justification that it's
completely wrong for their members of
parliament to sling out the prime
minister since he's the person they
wanted to lead the country and that's
why they voted to talk conservative and
that's why they voted for those mps what
do you think the general public british
voters make of all this ongoing
political theater all of these ongoing
scandals
yeah i mean in part if it's just viewed
as theater some people rather enjoy it
many more people find it very
frustrating and want it uh to be over
with but i'll tell you this if you think
this is unstable and if you think this
is theater you better imagine a long hot
summer of a conservative party
leadership election in which as many as
a dozen candidates might run to replace
boris johnson and then have to be
whittled down one by one until you get
to a final two that's voted on by the
membership in the country if you think
this is unstable you ain't seen nothing
yet
what do you think very briefly all of
this has done to trust in all political
officials and both sides of the house of
commons
well it may be an unfashionable view but
in my in my senses this is the system
working you know the party got it wrong
uh very chris pincher in the report that
paul just did he was right about the
issues former deputy chief whit uh the
party got it wrong about chris pincher
the prime minister got it wrong about
chris pincher and boy are they in
trouble as a result this is the system
working all right alex dean conservative
political commentator thank you